head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard charts I've
got bad news for you okay we know we can
sit here talk about the importance of
Journalism and fear about what's to come
in 2024 but the prophet of Doom a
psychic has predicted cyber attacks
natural disasters and a Russia China
Alliance well the prophet of Doom says
so I mean look at this guy he knows so
uh that's it that's it boys pack it in
uh you may as well just uh flee to El
Salvador while you still can because uh
we're here who is this prophet of Doom
he claims to see into the future and he
says that uh you know there's going to
be he's got some serious predictions big
floods will engulf London in Europe a
new pandemic in Australia and President
Vladimir Putin will trip off this Mortal
coil coffee with Craig that's the you
know what's really funny is like we're
kind of we're kind of making fun of this
dude and everything but what if all this
stuff actually came true well the global
uh Cyber attack that doesn't actually
feel like very specific of a prediction
for me it's like being like there will
be an election next year like get we
know all sorts of countries will have
elections next year I I wish they would
have some more specific details the
flood in London is kind of a bold choice
I think right that is a bold choice I
think the best way to go about this
would be to claim that a man from the
future gave you uh access to information
about what was going to happen and uh
that's what is going to happen unless
because telling you changes history it
doesn't happen but then it's not my
fault it's your fault actually it is
interesting that is a nice caveat to
always be like but well because I tried
to save you you know now now
everything's going to be different I
can't rely yeah that was uh do you guys
remember John
terer the it was a a meme thing in like
the 2000s a guy online posting on forums
claiming to be from the future and
showing pictures of like light bending
in a time machine and I think he was
saying that about 2008 the US would be
fractioned into four different countries
and stuff but of course he was like
however that may not happen because I've
altered the timeline oh there were some
really interesting and very intelligent
things that he said that made people is
he the one who said he like he traveled
through time to like three specific
points in time he came back multiple
times to warn people about things look
at this he's got a he's got a look at
thiser John terer and time travel zero
pyms used on internet forms between 200
2001 by an individual claiming to be an
American military time travel from 2036
so you're saying that in 13 years we got
time travel their post discussed various
aspects of time travel and described
future calaminus events including a
global nuclear war the uniform
inaccuracy of their predictions and
inconsistencies in their explanations
has led many to view the story with
skepticism wait that was it I kind of
think if a guy goes online and says I'm
from the future that instantly
disqualifies it from being true but okay
like maybe there's a 0.000000 1% Chance
some time traveler is telling the truth
it was a created by Larry Haber a
Florida entertainment lawyer and his
brother John Rick Haber a computer
scientist the claims have never been
verified however interesting okay I
think they know it was a hoax I've read
a lot about doomsayers throughout the
history of humanity and it's actually
more common than I think people realize
it's so easy to say that the worst thing
is going to happen and to make the
claims about all the the risks and how
they're all going to fail and that's
going to cause the end and the failure
but I think it's way more likely that
things are going to march on it's just a
matter of staying still surviving having
community and things I'm with you on
that I think I I'm I'm more of an
optimist I I think what a time to be
alive what a time to make a difference
right now and and and the truth is so
powerful I know it's very corny and
cliche and people are probably going to
laugh at this but you you have a dark
room just a little little flame it
lights up the room the truth is has that
power it just does and I think it'll
ultimately win as long as people are
courageous enough to say to say it and
and and historically and like the Soviet
Union these other countries they
couldn't say it they had to live by lies
they had to they had to pretend they
even though they knew the truth they
didn't want to say it and as long as we
have the courage to say it in numbers I
think we'll be okay and also the ability
to preserve it which I think storing
data in orbit like we really need to get
away from these centralized servers or
at least expand in a decentralized
storage the truth can be unfortunately
on the internet tweaked in real time the
truth I call it no that's true I mean we
we talked about this all the time people
like Netflix will take uh scenes out of
shows if they decide their un popular
incorrect it's weird that we edit the
content that we have it's like you're
unable to preserve an original document
which is crazy it's it's terrifying do
you have any white pill predictions for
uh 2024 anything particular you think
positive white pill I like that question
that's a good premise um as I said I
think the last couple weeks of 2023 if
or any precursor I think you're going to
see whatever the if there's corruption
or fraud
occurring like if there's a conspiracy
somewhere I think that conspiracy will
be made public for us to see now we
could argue whether that's going to make
a difference that's a different
conversation so if there's if there's
voter fraud and I don't know if there's
going to be enough of it but if there is
I think we'll see it in 2024 yeah in
other words we'll be able to see the
fraud happening on the inside the
whistleblowers will come public they'll
reveal it on video incontrovertible and
and now whether that now whether that's
going to be um
uh shocking enough to people who who
like for example hate orange man you
know bad very bad then then I don't know
but I think we'll be able to see it in a
way that we've never seen it before and
we're seeing it right it's like true
we're going to see it in a way we've
never seen it before I've never seen
anything like it are you're familiar
with the apocalypse from the Bible like
it's it's a Biblical prophecy entering
like the they call it the end times who
knows what that actually means if the
calendar is just resetting or something
but it it basically means apocal means
the great revealment the things are
being revealed and so what do you think
about things like neural net where
people are plugging into machines and
are we can share our thoughts I don't
know anything about that well it's just
the elon's way of making brain computer
interface a little better than using
fingers you can use your thoughts to
communicate on the machine now I feel
like norl net would be the worst thing
for whistleblowers right like if the
government or whoever was plugged into
your brain you started thinking maybe I
want to say something about what's going
on wherever I well there reports today
Ashley s Clair reported that the
American Airlines one of the airlines
was forcing people to download something
onto their phone the pilots
whether they talking to James o or not
and I just tweeted out just go to
Walmart and buy another phone and just
download signal but there efforts like
this and but even that you know in in
these other countries no descent was per
historically no descent was permitted at
all you know you and and and now you're
seeing the the the opposite effect like
it's almost you know you know Orwell
feared the truth would be concealed from
us Huxley feared the truth would be
drowned out in a sea of irrelevance
so the question Tim's point I think was
on point which is that our audience have
become so segmented how do you convince
the people that don't agree with you
don't just play to your audience play to
the people who don't agree and and and
to the white pill question I think I
believe still believe that if you if you
if you expose the truth in such a way
it'll convince the people that don't
agree with me like for example the story
on fizer or black rock or um or or even
voter fraud the problem with the voter
fraud I've heard from the right is that
I don't think anyone's ever actually
proved it I think it's all
circumstantial evidence I mean can you
name a a case where we've really
actually proved incontrovertible
evidence of massive voting fraud I
haven't seen that I haven't seen massive
that's I guess enough to swing an
election I I personally have I mean
there's different ways that they coers
you know propaganda the media but you
know what I'm saying I I think that
there's going to be people on the inside
in 2024 recording this stuff and there's
nothing they can do to stop it
hypothetically would you would you
support like a technology that just
blows everyone's Minds open so that we
can read every human's brain I didn't I
didn't even thought about the
implications of that I I would you would
you support that why because we're going
to destroy ourselves if we don't you
don't think people have the right to the
privacy of their own thoughts well no
not anymore I feel like look what people
did with that the secrecy and
destruction and slav slavit toe that
they've done to humans it's hor horrific
I don't like a world where I'm oblig to
let anyone read my mind that sounds
terrifying I just think that they
thought that it's your mind is like kind
of out of like our thoughts are not our
own it's our mind it is our mind it's
the global mind I mean obviously we have
autonomy as bodies My Little Pony it's
our little well not really if it's not
my mind it's not my body right I mean
what where do you draw this line um also
like to my point before that would
completely blow up a whistleblower
system right if if your thoughts were
public to everyone we would never have
anyone come forward because
theoretically they would immediately be
imprisoned if they even thought about
saying hey I should report this to
someone but the corruption would never
happen because if someone tried to ruin
the system managing this the corrup
species the entire species would be like
policing itself at all times kind of
whoever's on the top of that structure
would be policing it I don't think there
is a top if it's all I so I don't think
it's a good thing but I think Ian
presents a possible future that we've
actually talked about on the culture War
the way I describe it is with AI with
with neuralink and all this stuff what
eventually happens is humans will be
treated like cell like single cells in a
multicellular organism so uh take a look
at single cells right they're all
running around doing crazy hits and
whatnots they're eating stuff and making
more of themselves and they're
independent in and of themselves
multicellular organisms all the cells
have clearly defined roles and within
the multicellular organism like each and
every one of us here sometimes there are
rogue actors that want to be free they
want to be free and they want to do
whatever they want to do and what do we
call that cancer yes diseas and what do
we do to cogens usually we consume them
with white blood cells we destroy them
and so in a future where we're all
neurolink and we're all being given our
roles and to each according to their uh
need and you know from each according to
their capabilities what ends up
happening then is this nightmare
dystopia where you rip the neuralink out
of your neck and you're like I just want
to be me and then you're hunted down by
law enforcement who are all AI linked
mindless drones and then they destroy
you liquefy your body and convert you
into resource I don't think You' ever
want to want to disengage from the
species cancer ex I mean that's true and
maybe what I'm saying is I'm looking at
stripping human of joy and pain and love
and hate and all these things that make
it so wonderful but awful to be a human
but at the same time man those kids
pulling Cobalt out of the mines in
Africa where people are just like no no
no no no let's not look at that like
come on man it's like how many thousands
of kids are getting poisoned right now
CLA at that stuff for us to get our cell
phones and and yes and now do you weep
for the the the skin cells that die and
are flect off your body in an AI neural
net world when your brain is plugged
into the machine you'll know all about
it and you will you will not care it the
the people who are mining the Cobalt
won't care either they'll just be the
dead cells flaking off into the wind but
I feel like we would be working out of
our way to make sure humans don't have
to suffer through that stuff if we were
all one unit if your brain is linked to
an a neural net where everyone is like
one Hive they wouldn't be suffering
there would no longer be a you they
would be mindless
drones I don't know they'd be mindless
they'd be mindless I don't think we have
to worry about this prior to November 24
correct I think you're right I think I
think let's take it let's take it one
year at a time because there's a lot lot
going on you answer these big
philosophical question well I mean it's
a fascinating it's a fascinating
Pandora's box but to get back to to this
coming 20 this is the last show of the
year right Tim this is the last show of
year so a truly free press empowers
people to make decisions for themselves
and that's what this is this movement is
all about I mean you have the the the
the Press is is putting things in
simplifications and stereotypes and
obfuscation and and all types of of
carefully woven tapestry of words that
obfuscate and then you just have Elon
musk's X and whistleblowers and this is
all about empowering people to make
decisions because they have access to
information they previously did not and
it's the lack of transparency in the
world that is the advantage to the to
the evil so the theory the the white
pill is by making the world more
transparent than it's ever been not mind
I don't even know about that that's
a metaphysical thing I have I have to
really I have to sleep on that but let's
just take it to the next level just
having access to inside of Airlines
inside of the DHS inside the IRS inside
the FBI if those walls could talk
imagine if the American people could see
that and hear that for themselves
imagine that I actually think that the
the whatever the outcome would be would
be the correct one but right now people
have no idea what's happening and and
we're debating facts it's a the the the
greatest tragedy of modern society is we
debate facts why are we debating facts
we shouldn't be well we've made so many
things subjective right they have
decided they shouldn't be but there is a
whole whole bent of like I mean bringing
up every show but the gender stuff right
saying well gender is different than sex
and this is why you can feel this way
but actually this is that that's one
thing I I think that they they there's
there's a economic incentive to focus on
these kind of issues that divide people
but so wouldn't that be true for
anything that is fact that people try to
manipulate probably have an incentive to
do so corruptive coercive power of the
federal government the weaponization of
the federal government innocent
Americans I think these are winning
issues and the majority of people I also
think chopping off private parts off
little boy that's a winning issue 90% of
people think that's wrong I think if
people could see and hear the stench the
rot for themselves that's why I'm a
white pilled guy because I know it's
going to happen it's already happening
and you have people who come from inside
and come out and tell you hey I want to
talk about this because I think it's
wrong that must be a very uplifting
experience it's it's it's a a heavy
experience it's it's heavy uh I and and
and actually Tim you know one of the
things I I I've learned is you know we
were talking about this off off off air
is that it's hard for um yeah I got to
be careful who I surround myself with oh
yeah you know after what I've been
through and and I've got all these
people contacting me I got to make sure
people on my team close to me I can
trust them are people are people
possessed You by parasites yeah uh I
believe so it look the stuff I've
learned about your story the stuff I've
experienced it feels like one day a
demon enters their brain and takes them
over Dude I think they're literal
parasites in your gut I'm about to do
some combo it's this toad Venom and
apparently you puke up parasites and
they just come out Luke rowski has a we
are change video from seven years ago I
think there's much simpler ways the
combo stuff is about like experiencing
death or something yeah but also a purge
it's a purge of this what you're
doing for Christmas Ian no I don't know
ho ho ho baby yeah take me there no the
weird hippie dippy injecting what I've
learned is my fight and many fights like
this it's almost like a fight against
human nature it's almost like a fight
against self-interest for goodness or
for truth or for you know not betraying
your conscience and there's a lot of
people out there who are the world is
governed by people pursuing their own
self-interest so if you're going to run
against that tide you better make sure
that people who are around you share
those values or your partner shares your
values if you're going to be on a
mission against self-interest and I
think that's what it's going to take you
mentioned the founding fathers get with
their lives Fortune sacred honor blood
treasure and sacred honor Blas and they
did that for them for each other they
they they were risking their children
their children these are guys who were
wealthy had families and they could have
said look if we remain loyalists the
king will take care of us and we let
everyone else burn instead they said I
will stand with the people of my
community even though they had land
landed gentry and they told the king to
screw off they felt their children were
at risk either way right one what future
will I leave for my children Ben
Franklin lost his kid he he his son
William refused to ever speak to him
again because he he his son was a
loyalist he wouldn't leave the this such
a modern expence like I got to do what's
right my own son I think we all know
people whose whose families don't speak
to each other because of politics right
I know people who are like if you voted
for Trump I'll never speak to I'll never
speak to you again right like this is
something we still experience today but
if you believe that your country is at
risk if you believe the future of the
people you love could be damaged by an
outcome don't you feel more oblig
morally obligated to act William
Franklin was imprisoned by Patriots from
76 to 78 and he was the chief leader of
the loyalists in New York City
organizing military units to fight back
on the side of the British he went to
Exile in Britain and lived in London
until his death I never saw him again
crazy that's a wild sacrifice sometimes
the doing the right thing and the hard
thing are the same thing I'm at a tip
right now I can't you what it is or who
it is or where it is but it's big and I
I get these every 10 minutes quote I
don't know if this is Major new major
News James but I thought I would just do
the right thing and it reminds me of a
quote by um the big tobacco whist
Jeffrey Wan 1990s asked by Mike Wallace
why are you doing this gave up
everything he goes he goes because it's
right he said because it's right so
there are very we could all agree that
that's a very tiny fraction of humans
who would who would do that and say that
therefore Tim my fight is a fight
against uh human nature in many regards
and you said demonically possessed when
you're fighting against when you're
fighting against and we all have demons
right and every single one of us unless
you're a liar we all have things that
we're ashamed of perhaps that we've done
but if you're fighting for good what's
going to happen when you're fighting for
good you're going to be faced with Tim
you're going to be faced with with bad
people doing bad things and saying bad
things and demons you could say when you
say right and wrong I feel like that's
should always be up for debate because
like transparency for the sake of
transparency I'm not into anymore I i'
I've considered it throughout life but
like National Defense weapons programs
like the Manhattan Project we could not
if people have blown the whistle on that
and given the the specs to oh we talked
about this at turning point if if they'd
revealed open- Source the data for the
nuclear bomb and Hitler got it and built
it first we'd all be speaking General
hang on you the guy who just pitched
that all of our thoughts should be
public is are noted to transparency for
he sayfe if you could flip a switch
maybe but uh maybe but uh yeah yeah
there's some things that where you need
I'm not following that's a good point
thank you but the journalist is there's
a book written about this called the
custodians of conscience the custodians
of contrin you you you you you the
information revealer forms the moral
values by releasing the information and
testing and affirming what is and what
is not moral you you realize that by
going oh I called my company OMG oh my
God like when the fizer guy is saying we
make fake things to lie to customers to
make money or Black Rock saying we
control the world we bribe politicians
okay that's wrong and that's that's the
kind of role of transparency is it not
to to test and affirm what is and what
is not moral by revealing information
that shocks the conscience you're the
custodian of the Public's conscience
they're going to like Quantum encryption
hacking is a big technology like 2028
we're going to start seeing people be
able to go in and like open up the last
20 years of your bank records like
everyone on Earth they're Bank like and
and so is that conscionable to do is is
it cons do it just to some and not to
others but do people need to know that
it's happening is the question right do
people know that that's occurring or
should they know that that that's
occurring I think so but
sometimes yes in that instance yes
sometimes I don't sometimes there are
things that are happening that if people
know they panic and and that could do
more harm than keeping them in the dark
then that's the balance that you have to
strike as the publisher of the
information do some things should not be
some things ought to be kept secret but
I think you you you derive your sense of
morality through the reporting process
and the public changes their sense of of
what is right and wrong based upon
whether it whether it tugs at their
conscience the word is conscience I
would say thanks for watching this from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net